returning now to our other main story
this hour and the latest developments in
the impeachment proceedings against US
President Donald Trump a short time ago
the heads of several houses of House of
Representatives committees along with
the Speaker Nancy Pelosi unveiled two
articles of impeachment against
President Trump those would still have
to be approved by the full house
something that's likely to happen in the
coming days Jerry Nadler the chair of
the US House Judiciary Committee
explained why House Democrats have
chosen to move forward with the two
articles of impeachment in service to
our duty to the Constitution and to our
country the House Committee on the
judiciary is introducing two articles of
impeachment charging the President of
the United States Donald J Trump with
committing high crimes and misdemeanors
the first article is for abuse of power
it is an impeachable offense for the
President to exercise the powers of its
public office to obtain an improper
personal benefit while ignoring or in
injuring the national interest this
gives rise to the second article of
impeachment for obstruction of Congress
here too we see a familiar pattern and
president Trump's misconduct a president
who declares himself above
accountability above the American people
and above Congress's power of
impeachment which is meant to protect
against threats to our democratic
institutions is the president who sees
himself as above the law we must be
clear no one not even the president is
above the law Heidi Joe Castro is live
for us on Capitol Hill joins us now live
on al Jazeera Heidi as expected two
articles of impeachment against
President Trump announced by the
Democrats won on abuse of power the
other on obstruction of Congress talk us
through what they've laid out here
right and this is a huge development
today fully because these are synonymous
to the charges that Trump now would be
facing if this goes to a trial in the
Senate and all signs are this is where
the impeachment is headed of course with
his very presidency at stake whether or
not he remains in office you heard just
now Jerry Nadler chair of the Judiciary
Committee lay out those two articles
that Trump will be facing abuse of power
relating to how he pressured Ukraine to
investigate Trump's political rivals Joe
Biden and his son while withholding US
security aid to Ukraine and withholding
a coveted White House invitation for the
president of Ukraine the Nadler went on
to say that this was part of a pattern
of abusing his power by Trump also
mentioning in 2016 how the Trump
campaign welcomed foreign interference
in that election and now is soliciting
it from Ukraine and continues to do so
today on that second article of
impeachment on obstruction of Congress
Adam Schiff the House Intelligence chair
said that this was unprecedented the way
that the White House has refused to turn
over evidence and refuse to allow staff
members to testify to to cooperate with
impeachment investigators ship went on
to say that this would be completely it
would decimate in his words Congress's
ability to conduct oversight for this
president and for future presidents
laying this out as a historic moment not
only decisive in this in the presidency
of Donald Trump but also with
implications for presidents to come for
generations to come
shifts of that this was an extraordinary
remedy to recommend articles of
impeachment and that Democrats were
doing so with reluctancy however because
of the clear and present danger that
Trump continues to
to the country's national security
Democrats say that is why they are
pressing forward and the House Judiciary
Committee Heidi aiming to vote on these
articles of impeachment no later than
Thursday so it's happening quite quickly
here that's right an understanding is
that staff members worked overnight
after that last Judiciary Committee
hearing in order to get the language of
these impeachment articles drafted and
released to the world just this morning
so we're expecting on Thursday for the
House Judiciary to commit committee to
vote these articles out to the full
floor and then next week for the Full
House floor to vote and very likely
impeach the president of course
Democrats control the majority in the
house once this thing reaches the Senate
which is the body that will be trying
the president to determine his guilt or
innocence
that's when more suspense will kick in
we're not sure how that will turn out
Republicans have the majority in the
Senate and Trump certainly has the
advantage in that at least 20 Republican
senators would have to defect from him
in order to convict him and remove him
from office but it's still early
Democrats say that this evidence is
damning enough and they are going to
make this effort they say to hold the
president accountable Heidi thank you
for that Heidi Joe Castro on Capitol
Hill for us let speak some more about
this not to joseph hora who's an
associate professor of political science
at Texas A&M University thank you so
much for being with us once again on
al-jazeera this is no doubt a
make-or-break moment for both sides for
both both Republicans and Democrats have
the Democrats in your view managed to
successfully lay out what they think
Donald Trump did wrong well the the
Intelligence Committee hearings that the
preceded the judiciary's work this week
certainly offered a compelling set of
facts for the American public the
testimony of senior diplomatic officials
of ambassadors and career diplomats
really laid out how the president's
actions violated norms of how
the u.s. conducts foreign policy why it
was contrary to the interests of the
United States a lie to withhold aid from
Ukraine and to withhold the White House
meeting from Ukraine's president
Solinsky and and you know separately why
these actions would have been -
president Trump's advantage in the next
election and so I think the the set of
facts that they've laid out are in a
very straight line with the articles of
impeachment they introduced today why
did they introduce just two articles of
impeachment in the end and not three as
was expected well what do you think the
strategy here these I think the strategy
is to focus on the the to substantive
issues where the the evidence is
strongest and most clear and where the
judiciary and Intelligence Committee
hearings have really focused the
public's attention of course there have
been months and years of allegations
about wrongdoing on the part of the
president and his administration the the
interactions with you can train the
calls to investigate a political
opponent right those are clearly over
the line sort of clear violations of the
sort of standards that Americans have
historically had for their president and
are really sort of the the most
clear-cut case of President Trump acting
in ways that are violations of both his
oath of office and and sort of
deviations from the the nation's best
interests joseph ora the expectation is
as Heidi said barring any surprises is
that lawmakers will vote along party
lines in the house and in the Senate if
it goes there will it be ultimately the
American voters who decides Donald
Trump's fate I mean if things continue
as they have been where where decision
making and Congress is dominated by
bipartisanship the house will vote to
impeach the Senate will fail to remove
the president from office and incumbent
president Trump will seek reelection
next year so certainly the American
voters will have a say in this in the
end but their fair reaction to all this
is weighing on lawmakers and as you know
more facts potentially come out as
witnesses and testimony
appear before the Senate it's it remains
to be seen whether or not Republican
senators facing re-election or senators
keeping an open mind about this process
may in fact deviate from our
expectations and vote to convict the
president thank you so much for your
thoughts Joseph aura from Texas A&M
University joining us here on al-jazeera
thank you for your time